welcome to this video legend 2014 from
Turkey yeah
did I play yes once and I lost okay
oh yeah this laughs yeah what can I do I
can hmm and do something else maybe
something like this g3 just for a
different kind of position it's an
interesting move that and I would like
to take on c4 or play Bishop yeah this
is this kind of thing I'm aiming for a
quick Queen b3 let me think about this
is it Queen b3 now I think
[Music]
yeah black now has to to choose between
taking on b3 for this end game type of
position that is always somewhere
between very slightly better forwarded
equal or go back to c7 he cannot go to a
six do to e4 okay he decided to go there
come on it's important to try to get rid
of this bishop okay and one key idea is
a quick efore here's white at the moment
he is not able to play b6 I can just
take it twice and I'm going to go with
afore early yeah I guess cancels and
then you form
oh that's a very ambitious move without
any development let's see okay I'm going
to take it yeah yeah ambitious is just a
nice way of saying I think it is bad but
it's complicated age - age - Hanks this
is this is not really a problem
I wonder yeah how to do that that's not
easy we can go six for starters then
Quincy to e for isms mmm it's not easier
many have many possibilities many
possibilities I can also play h3h3
Knight takes Bishop takes Knight takes
e4 for opening up the position okay
that's not the best continuation
probably but something that looks
manageable and and is okay for white I
believe so takes takes Eve form maybe he
can play d4 maybe he can
start youth before now yeah okay that
wasn't that wasn't the best continuation
as I as I already suspected but it's
difficult he tried to refute their their
bad opening play all the time you will
lose on time very often which which
happened to me quite a lot so if or
Defour is hanging on for black the
sacrifice on d5 is probably playable but
not not 100% correct
very likely okay and they have curious
curious how I could have refuted this
completely it was definitely possible
[Music]
and 92 we can really just take the pawn
on c5 which is which is a problem
[Music]
what is he doing then quincy for what
probably
[Music]
yeah if for Queen G for something like
that
[Music]
okay yeah I mean still
what what what exactly is happening okay
let's play that and see if he kills me
now what whatever he okay this check
check okay so he's this is a drone can
you play for a win here even often you
had this prom do you drawing right now I
cannot avoid it game drunk a word
avoided yeah I'm curious how I could
have refuted this so let's see night
reform what is what is best here H form
h4 is the refutation of this huh
now that didn't really occur to me this
is this is how it is done the norm
threatening a form and why this white is
clearly better he's not developed yeah
this is something that is just just the
key point this is the one
okay I'm not difficult this is this is
probably not not doing that much
originally I wanted to play E for here
but then I noticed that I mean I did
play that but I was thinking here but he
can really just take the pawn there is
no good continuation here whatsoever if
I attacked the pawn he will really just
cover it and I don't have anything right
here yeah okay computer says f4 this is
clearly better for me but but I was I
was a bit afraid of that one oh I
totally overlooked
I totally overlooked that I'm that I'm
meeting first I was thinking that rook
takes two three now as this is a bit bit
of a problem but F 2 is f7 is of course
the issue so then I can do that I mean
he has no squares for this piece it's
relatively best according to the engine
is this one which is just that just plus
one just kind of surprising what is this
five points it's got two points you know
maybe this this yeah and then f4 needs
to this this drawn check check check it
here there is no way to play for wynia
here I might even lose and here yeah he
can check check with that I should make
sure enough like that okay yeah
interesting interesting
thanks for watching